spring in mark Whalberg his new movie is
instant family hits theaters next Friday
that's November 16th and he co-stars
with Rose Byrne we like Rose Byrne and
Mark joins us now how are you mark I'm
doing okay I don't know if you heard
what they're gonna do they're gonna let
everybody see when the NBA has their
all-star picks so two captains are gonna
then they're gonna pick their all-star
teams on TV so you get to see it in real
time what do you think about that what
do you think I love it because I want a
little tension I think I think there's
too much familiarity friendship in the
NBA III let me ask you a question so
when they when the two main guys are
picked with LeBron or curry or Kevin
Durant and then the other people that
they have they just pick anybody they
have to pick from the people have been
voted in ten and been selected for the
all-star game
I don't know I think it's it you're
voted in you have your rosters at 24 and
then the two captains are gonna pick
after that I think it would be fun I
just need I need I'm thinking Chris Rock
might be a good host like I need
somebody who's going to be stirring it
up and it
yeah jabbing some people know wills too
nice could you take Will Ferrell yeah
you know first of all wouldn't want to
get him too upset I mean we fought a
little bit and you know we wrestled
we're already on the ground so I kind of
able to kind of even even the size
differential but you don't want to get
the big man going you know you like to
know you like to wrestle you like to
wrestle with guys right I don't make a
habit
but you're with Peter Berg in this great
direct euler director and you've got
wine and you're directing you know
you're wrestling on a flight with each
other it was an unprovoked attack
unprovoked attack if a prayer is
provoking then I'm guilty I'm Pete and I
are actually shooting a movie right now
in Boston what are you shooting this
film it's called Wonderland it's a crime
drama set in Boston with a lot of humor
an edge with Alan Arkin Winston boots
and a great cast we're very excited but
do you all of a sudden get that accent
back like it's it's a little heavier
once you go back to Boston you know what
I'm purposely not doing a Boston accent
in this movie I am in Boston but I'm not
necessarily playing the kind of typical
Boston guy were you shooting outside
your old house that you grew up in yes
one directly across the street I grew up
in 25 he was shooting at 24 how surreal
is that and it was just a coincidence
you know what it was it was crazy it was
really bizarre you know and I told
people I try to get out of there for a
reason pull any bar if that house could
tell stories there's a lot of stories a
lot of stories yeah yeah from from 11 to
18 I love their prime time the new movie
is instant family hits theaters next
Friday November 16th I was wondering
about this knowing that you were coming
on today if you could have been or could
be in any TV series as an actor what
would you want to be in I'll have to go
back to one of the series that I watched
growing up so it'd have to be US troop
or Barney Miller or you know one of the
classics on the Sun Emily yeah you know
Happy Days I'm gonna have to be tougher
than Henry Winkler upon I mean come on
but no I you know I grew up watching
great great television
a lot of mrs. Blayne television now but
uh yeah I'd have to go back to one of
the ones that girl watch with my dad
what about movie you can be in any movie
ooh
Godfather hard times Charles Bronson
bare-knuckle fighting Stephen Queen are
you there
nope we lost him for saying Prince Neil
track him down so the new movie is
instant family Rose Byrne always rose in
wait where did we see her damages
premiere Oh damages in New York she's
also in neighbors neighbors oh I loved
her in neighbors a versus but but when I
saw Rose Byrne she came up to me and she
said thank you for having me and I it
wasn't my party and I said well you're
welcome
I didn't know what that meant but I
always thought I was very honored that
Rose Byrne said thank you for having me
you're welcome Rose Mark Wahlberg is
back and you were saying mark Rose
yeah she was very sweet very talented I
loved her sense of humor I think she's
sneaky sneaky funny and and she happens
to be yeah I'm a huge huge fan
absolutely loved her worked with Bobby
kind of only a couple times but she
loves but you get to pick your co-star
right because Saturday Adam Sandler
would always go I go how did you get
that woman in the movie and go Danny
I picked them so do you get to pick oh
you can start with well I was cast first
and we we certainly had her right at the
top of the wish list but what happened
was and I think what what would
continues to happen is you know if you
got a great part and in particularly
this movie is a fantastic part for a
female I mean Ellie was you know I
wanted to play Ellie when I read it so
you get you get to kind of track that
level of talent
I was on the page so I don't think it
was me I think it was it was what Sean
wrote in the part and she did a
fantastic job are you gonna take any in
any Patriots or Celtics games oh you
know what I haven't watched a single
game the only even the World Series I
watched the first three out of the top
of the first and Game three and I woke
up I was in New York actually working I
woke up and I was like all day replaying
the game how cool oh my god so I was
lucky in that every time I didn't watch
day one so going to bed at 6:30 I were
just kind of I watched patriot games
that are the 1 o'clock East Coast games
but other than that I've been going to
bed wait what time you go to bed 6:30
east coast or west coast well how does
that work with your family you know what
I'm on the East Coast working under the
kids just crack up when I'm waiting for
them come out of school take a FaceTime
and say goodnight the crap out of my
wife
well what time you have dinner they're
not usually 4:30 5 o'clock dinner and
you're no fun oh you know what I'm gonna
be a crazy wild fun guy starting at
about 5 weeks I'm done with the movie
I'll be doing whatever I want
eating drinking having a good old time
have you have you ever just let yourself
go yeah I just do whatever is required
for the part that I'm playing like when
I did Deepwater Horizon I put on 25
pounds eating fried food in Louisiana
every day so I really just depends on
what I'm doing but for this particular
part and Pete bird by the way is the
worst influence so here's like do
everything you can you got to be ripped
on each shape and then it's like we got
to go to dinner
well I'm whitener right I can't do both
if you want me to be in shape then I got
to eat right we discipline and go to bed
well yeah but you're fine all right
every day to like one think I'm gonna
look different come date 35
like oh well whatever we'll figure that
out
what's the biggest number you ever rang
up on a bar bill or dinner bill with 100
God in France
I mean Louie there they go they go very
high that's you know what my birthday my
30th birthday with Ari and the whole
crew probably 30 or 40 30 40 grand yeah
but there was 15 of us now do you have
to buys it assume that you're picking up
the tab I didn't pick up that one but I
don't mind picking up the top no 30th
birthday that was that was a wild one so
the new movie instant family hits
theaters next Friday November 16th and
go out and see Rose Byrne crack up Mark
Wahlberg who's the worst one you ever
worked with of trying to keep a straight
face actor oh you will will and Adam
McKay I mean Adam McKay is as funny as
anybody but enough so I think the
combination of those two it's pretty
difficult to keep a straight face
well good luck with the shooting up
there tell Berg we said hello as always
and great to talk to you mark thank you
guys I appreciate that that's a mark
wahlberg for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]